and there are reports this morning that
the shadow cabinet is bracing itself for
a reshuffle after a number of Labour's
front benches voted in favor of
airstrikes in Syria despite winning the
Oldham by-election it's been a
challenging week for the party calls for
unity have come hand in hand for some
with a barrage of online abuse might
join now by one of Momentum's organizers
Adam plug very good to see mr. flood
tell me first of all a lot of people
might not know what what momentum is are
your party within a party hi thank you
my momentum is trying to build a
grassroots social movement to channel
the energy and enthusiasm over the
summer for the election of Jeremy Corbyn
as Labour leader and try and harness
that into building something positive
progressive and inclusive where voices
outside of Westminster I heard and where
people are not can organize on issues
which affect them in their local area
ISM but you're all you're all labor part
of me party members and only Labour
Party members everybody who has a
position within momentum is a Labour
Party member and only a Labour but I
cannot be a member of another political
party yes absolutely cannot and also at
meetings the governance structure is
still being sort of established to be
completely clear with all the
terminology but absolutely no members of
other political parties are welcome at
momentum meetings if you're not a member
of a political party
or if you remember the Labour Party then
your voice is welcomed and hurt but we
absolutely do not Socialist Party for
example are not welcome to be at
milland's and meetings cleanse this
party Great Britain exactly like okay
well you know the charge you must have
heard it often by now that you are in
some way shape or form a housefly term
it the the on line in particular
petroleum guard of Jeremy Corbyn that
you are there to to police protect and
punish those that to disagree with your
views I think that's a misunderstanding
of what momentum are are doing and I
think if you go if you meet anyone who's
been involved in momentum or go to any
momentum events there's a positive
inclusive atmosphere whereby people
having their voice heard and for example
on the serious situation
there was a talk momentum provided a
tool whereby supporters could Lobby
their MPs on the issue if they felt they
felt inclined to do so and over 30,000
people did so if a very very small
number of people behaved in a manner you
know trolling more which being so called
bullying or harassing obviously I
Elementor would absolutely condemn that
100% and what to do about it I mean
because you mentioned that Syria boat
that was gonna get on set today I'm
following you got a list of æneas list
of 66 Labour MPs who voted in favor of a
bombing campaign and I don't know if
that momentum supporters are what but an
awful lot of them we had one of them
Chris Bryant in getting some really
serious abuse well I think as I say
obviously people conducting themselves
in a manner which isn't in accordance
with Jeremy Corbyn in his way of doing
politics I would not condone at all but
overwhelmingly people just wanted to
have their voice heard we live in a
democracy whereby individual citizens
party members constituents were lobbying
their MPs to speak about their views on
an issue which I think was deeply you
know I think it was a very ill thought
through and divisive moved to be going
for airstrikes in Syria I think we
should be focusing on diplomatic efforts
we should be looking at where Isis get
their arms where they get that money
these are the sorts of issues but these
66 MPs
you'd like to see them stay within the
Labour Party at the next election you
don't want them to be selected it's not
the role of momentum is not to be
campaigning on the selection or the
selection of of MPs that is for a
constituency labour parties so that
that's not the purpose of momentum
momentum is people coming together
organizing on issues which affect them
before Eddie had democracy SOS which was
a campaign to raise the issue of
individual electoral registration
whereby nearly 2 million people will
drop off the Electoral Register that has
been people going out in communities and
having conversations with people about
these changes which many people aren't
aware of so ensure that their voices are
heard and they don't drop off the
register similarly we've been opposing
George Osborne's cuts to tax credits
sort of work penalty as we were
- it has people who sell the whole Labor
Party but yeah I just just need to our
show yeah about the issue of the of the
front bench about the Shadow Cabinet
would you momenta
not prefer it if Jeremy Corbyn had more
people sitting there who agree with him
um I don't think it's a minterms
role to be making decisions about who
about the makeup at a Shadow Cabinet
that's down to Jeremy Corbyn the leader
so that's not an issue which but people
are saying he's strengthened after that
showing in the Elden by-election that he
could now say to some of those people
sitting on the front bench I don't want
you here anymore and the party wouldn't
go into revolt would you like to see
that and what I'd like to see is what
happened last Saturday in Oldham whereby
momentum helped mobilize to hundreds of
its supporters to come up and campaign
forward a fantastic and that a.m. Jim
McMahon who was very very welcoming him
and his team are very welcoming of
momentum there were coaches that came
from Leeds Bradford Birmingham London
Sheffield and there was a social in the
evening where Jim at mom or aim he spoke
he said he was overwhelmed by the
support for may well have had an effect
on the on the scale of that result but
you're happy let's just be explicit
about this you're happy with Maria Eagle
staying in the Shadow Cabinet with
Hilary Benn remaining there it's really
not my role to be talking about as I
said the makeup over the shadow cabinet
I think the role of the motives that you
know you directly oppose their policy
when it comes to things like airstrikes
I as I say I personally did oppose that
policy that vote is now gone through I'm
very very disappointed about the outcome
of it but I think on that vote Karen
people like that people it's a broad
church people like that should stay on
the front bench representing the Labour
Party as I say it's not my call to make
that comment but I think what that vote
showed on Syria was actually Jeremy
Corbyn the party is far more unified the
United than it is sometimes presented as
in the media
Jeremy Corbyn had I think 75% of members
who responded said they were opposed to
airstrikes which was his position I
believe 66 percent of MPs
back to his position and that wasn't
seem to be the case all along so I think
he showed real leadership and similarly
the majority the shadow cabinet also
supported Jerry's position ok mr. Kleck
very good seeing you thank you very much